now I'd like to see us go after this in
a very sincere way I think it should
have the same sincerity we had in Snow
White as we do it and as we tell the
story we believe in it ourselves
it's a once upon a time story and I
don't think we should be afraid of a
thing like that
what is Cinderella dreaming about
Cinderella would be dreaming of living a
life like other girls going to prom
meeting a man and falling in love some
of the dress coach and the prince could
be the door prize she says she's going
to send Cinderella off in style it's
beautiful
you have a very clever girl here and we
have to give her every chance to give us
her interpretation of the scene that's
the whole basis for using live-action
then we can build the final thing from
what we have yes my child but like all
dreams well I'm afraid this can't last
forever fairy godmother could say be on
your way child break hearts have fun but
don't forget on the stroke of 12:00
everything will be as it was before
everything will be as it was before the
fairy godmother would warn Cinderella
but Cinderella would sort of be
absent-minded about the warning I think
you should say on the stroke of 12:00
that would give us 11 strokes in between
for suspense
[Music]
[Applause]